foreign
Halle Berry keeping it real that's what
I do the actress shares this behind the
scenes video struggling to get into her
pants
help me I am helping you I'm filming it
this is called for the help of Halley's
stylist Lindsey Flores
trying to figure it out Hallie's got
some serious self-roasting skills too
she busted out the iconic SpongeBob Meme
poking fun at the whole situation
no I was having an out-of-body
experience but the video ended before
fans found out if she ever got wardrobe
ready let that be a mystery to the world
now Hallie's no stranger to teasing
herself
posted this clip on Instagram last month
from a charity event where she took a
tumble on her way to the stage but
turned the embarrassing moment into
comedic gold
[Applause]
yep that's me you're probably wondering
how I ended up in this situation
[Applause]
oh my God
and Hallie had a warning for anyone
thinking of spreading the clip online
[Applause]
from A Little Fall to a fashion
emergency seems the actress has no shame
in laughing at herself never dare a girl
like me to do anything
[Music]
thank you